in diesem ökosystem hat dann auch als
ein so unglaublicher gedanke platz und
kann gedeihen wie es könnte ein vorteil
sein wenn ich meine kinder um
[Musik]
frank urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
gerichtspsychiater der schweiz
wenn die medien fragen haben liefert er
antworten wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten fälle mit denen er als
gutachter zu tun hatte in der nacht von
23 auf den 24 dezember 2007 wurde die
polizei zu einer familienwohnung in
horgen im kanton zürich gerufen und
stellte dort fest dass die beiden kinder
zwillinge siebenjährig mit dem kissen
erstickt waren
das heißt die beiden kinder waren tot
und in der wohnung waren ansonsten
anwesend die mutter und der vater es gab
ein paar hinweise auf eine unordnung das
sah aus wie es hätte sein können man
stellt aber sehr schnell fest dass
niemand von außen eingedrungen war und
somit war klar es gab zwei tote personen
zu erlebende und dass die täterschaft
bei den lebenden personen zu suchen ist
ein tatort zwar die verdächtige sein
geständnis
das ist die situation als frank urbaniok
in diesem fall zugezogen wird
ich habe das gutachten sowohl über die
mutter als auch den vater gemacht und zu
dem zeitpunkt wo ich das gutachten
gemacht habe musste man annehmen
einer von beiden ist täter oder
täterinnen und ein anderes unschuldig
das ist eine sehr spezielle situation
als die mutter zum prozess gefahren wird
liegt noch immer kein geständnis vor
im gegenteil sie beteuert ihre unschuld
urbaniok tritt vor gericht als gutachter
auf und soll antworten auf die vielen
offenen fragen liefern
der gutachter also ich darf er keine
aussagen darüber machen zu sachverhalten
im sinne von der es schuldig der es uns
schuldig das steht allein im gericht zu
es ist so man nennt das eine
gerichtliche sachverhalts würdigung das
ist verboten das gebiet nimmt sich hat
und auch richtigerweise ist das aber
hier kommt das gutachten dieser grenze
schon sehr sehr nahe denn ich habe
sowohl die mutter als auch den vater
begutachtet und meine schlussfolgerung
waren so für die mutter kann ich einen
plausiblen delikt mechanismus dagegen
das bedeutet ich habe
persönlichkeitseigenschaften gefunden
mit denen ich zumindest theoretisch das
delikt erklären konnte ich habe nach
solchen persönlichkeitseigenschaften bei
dem vater auch gesucht habe die auch
nicht gefunden
das heißt die situation war so für die
mutter konnte ich einen delikt
mechanismus darlegen dem gericht für den
vater konnte ich das nicht
soweit können ein gutachter vor gericht
gehen aber auf keinen fall weiter
das war ja damals eingeschworenen
gerichtsprozess einer der letzten
geschworenengerichts prozesse und ich
erinnere mich gut daran dann fragte
einer der geschworenen fragte dann aber
jetzt sagen sie doch mal die täterin
haben das erklärt und dargelegt
trauen sie ihr das zu und ich habe schon
gesehen
der gerichtspräsident zusammenzuckt weil
wenn ich in dem moment auch nur
irgendeinen zeichen gegeben hätte gesagt
hat ja oder oder irgendetwas dann hätte
ich die grenze ganz klar überschritten
und damit wäre ich auch absolut in dem
moment mit befangenheit aus dem spiel
gewesen
das ist die grenze die darf ich nicht
überschreiten ich muss sagen ich kann es
aus meinem fachgebiet kann ich plausible
szenarien darlegen kann ich verbindung
zwischen persönlichkeitseigenschaften
die ich sehe und der tat verhalten kann
ich da legen im einen fall in dem
anderen fall nicht stoppt da ist die
rote linie
jetzt ist das gericht am zug das gericht
und die geschworenen hören an diesem tag
auch wie die angeschuldigte versuchte
den gutachter bewusst in die irre zu
führen
es wurden sehr viele möglichkeiten
ausgeschlossen bis man am schluss dann
das herausarbeiten konnte was dieses
individuelle profil bei dieser täterin
war und kurz bevor diese arbeit
abgeschlossen war sagte sie dann
beiläufig und übrigens ich bin
schlafwandlerin und hat damit natürlich
nahe gelegt
könnte das nicht so sein dass sie quasi
im schlaf wandeln das getan hat und sich
gar nicht mehr daran erinnern kann und
das ist noch heikel weil es gibt in der
tat in der literatur fälle in denen dann
täter als schuldunfähig erklärt wurden
weil man gesagt hat die haben im
schlafwandeln das gemacht und können
sich gar nicht daran erinnern als es
könnte im zweifelsfall noch so sein dass
man sagt ja man kann es ja gar nicht
ausschließen ob das nicht so ist
und das hat eine große problematik in
den fall hinein gebracht und
ich habe mir damals überlegt wie können
wir das angehen wir können wir damit
umgehen und sie hat mir gegenüber dann
geäußert es gibt eine bestimmte tablette
immer wenn sie diese tablette nimmt dann
tritt das schlafwandeln auf und ich habe
das sehr genau nach gefahr ist dass
immer der fall hat es hat ja das ist
immer der fall und an dem tatabend habe
sie auch diese tablette genommen und
dann haben wir gesagt gut dann bringen
wir die täterin in das schlaflabor und
wir zeichnen die hirnaktivitäten während
des schlafs auf erstmal ohne tabletten
und da hat sich überhaupt nichts
auffälliges gefunden
dann habe ich wieder mit ihr gesprochen
habe ich gesagt da ist nichts
auffälliges und jetzt werden wir aber
das gleiche nochmal machen mit der
tablette und in dieser nacht sieht man
dann dass die täterin aufsteht und
roboterhaft ein paar schritte macht und
sich wieder ins bett liegt und es sieht
aus wie schlafwandeln
aber man hat in dem moment ja die
hirnströme aufgezeichnet und wusste das
war kein schlafwandeln das war im
wachzustand das war vorgetäuscht
später gesteht die frau die tat und gibt
zu schon ihr erstes kind getötet und
einen plötzlichen kindstod vorgetäuscht
zu haben
ein zentraler problembereich eine
zentrale problem eigenschaft in diesem
fall war der sogenannte instabile
realitätsbezug das bedeutet dass
menschen sich ganz wenig verpflichtet
fühlen der realität subjektiv können sie
das sagen und das glauben was sich
subjektiv gut anfühlt unabhängig davon
ob das stimmt ob das plausibel ist ob
das mit irgendeiner wahrnehmung
übereinstimmt oder nicht also im
extremfall könnte man sagen ein mensch
mit instabilen realitätsbezug der kann
auf einer wiese kann der einen hasen
sehen und kann sagen weil sich das für
ihn gut anfühlt der ist rosa und wenn
ich jetzt kommen unser aber der ist doch
grau dann wird der mensch mit voller
überzeugung wir sagen aber guckt doch
hinter ist auch moser und das geht
deswegen weil bei diesen menschen quasi
die kopplung zwischen wahrnehmungen
zwischen gedanken zwischen emotionen das
ist völlig frei kombinierbar und sie
setzen das so zusammen wie das für sie
sich gut stimmig anfühlt und können
deswegen ganz absurde dinge stimmig für
sich denken als richtig erachten war
finden und da hat dann in diesem umfeld
in dieser wenn man so will in diesem
ökosystem hat dann auch ist ein so
unglaublicher gedanke platz und kann
gedeihen wie es könnte ein vorteil sein
wenn ich meine kinder um
wieso mussten die zwillinge an
weihnachten 2007 sterben
auch diese frage beantwortet der
gutachter dem gericht das motiv ist am
ende dass diese täterin die komplexität
ihres lebens reduziert hat die hat in
gewisser weise also es klebt man mag das
fast kaum aussprechen aber hat sich hat
dann gedacht das wäre das leben wäre
einfacher ohne die kinder sich dann
später auch noch mal gesagt dass sie
grundsätzlich auch immer die kinder
abgelehnt habe dass sie einen gewissen
hass neid auch sie verspürt hat aber
letztlich war sie hat sich vorgestellt
ein leben mit kindern ein leben ohne
kinder und subjektiv war für sie ein
leben ohne die kinder war dann die
attraktivere welt die attraktive
variante und da spielt der instabile
realitätsbezug eine große rolle
es gibt ja sonst auch mal eltern die
sagen wie wäre das leben ohne die kinder
oder wer hätte das nicht vorteile oder
in einer situation aber man würde
natürlich sofort so einen gedanken
verwerfen und würde sagen das darf man
gar nicht weiterdenken weil einem sofort
1000 gegen argumente einfallen jetzt
gewalttätig zu werden und das ist eben
der instabile realitätsbezug
in diesem umfeld gibt es die bremse
nicht gibt es nicht die realität
kontrolle gibt es nicht das denkt doch
noch mal darüber nach sondern es passt
in einem moment ist passt in eine
stimmung es passt in ein gefühl und wird
dann ganz zwanglos eingearbeitet und
kann dann zur realität werden was bei
anderen menschen nie sich so
weiterentwickeln konnte die täterin wird
schließlich zu einer lebenslänglichen
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt verbunden mit
einer ambulanten therapie